let's go to our next caller our next
caller is from the 7:01 area code caller
from 701 say hello introduce yourself
and then tell me what's on your mind
today
hey David
Paul from Fargo North Dakota great I was
kind of thinking okay thanks I was kind
of thinking about a neutral strategy and
I've been thinking about this for a
while and I kind of did a little
research to see if I could find some
hard facts or information about like a
new strategy why Democrats keep losing
trying to figure out a new strategy and
I wonder if if you are maybe the viewers
are aware of a specific study that's
been done a very simple one just calling
red skates or swing states and saying
this one question what would make you
vote for a Democrat over a Republican
and then taking that data and breaking
the answers into categories and
percentages and then kind of taking that
and making a platform or adjusting the
current one as necessary okay very good
so and I think about a couple aspects of
that number one the idea you're already
thinking in the right line of thought by
saying that Democrats need to come up
with some kind of cohesive strategy and
between you know corporate Democrats and
progressive Democrats and establishment
there needs to be some kind of uniting
platform that goes beyond we aren't
Trump and we aren't the Republicans so
that's really really good number two
where you're on the right track is in
trying to figure out well okay a
progressive center-left moderates
Democrats etc they're overwhelmingly
going to vote for the Democratic
candidates so what can be done to expand
the pie of people that might vote for a
Democrat or the more progressive
candidate in an election and why not go
to the issues and try to figure that out
the only place where I would be careful
is we're usually incredibly critical of
politicians who come up with basically
pull tested positions because it ends up
feeling inauthentic and while you could
certainly start calling around that and
saying hey what would make you in
Missouri as a Republican vote for a
Democrat and
would make you in Arizona vote for a
Democrat and whatever you'd get useful
information but crafting a platform
around that I would worry would be part
of the same corporate approach to
Democrats Inc as I call it well I do
like this
Peter Bogosian ask epistemology type
approach the problem is I think you're
really trying to appeal to the
independence in the middle who can be
swayed one way or another and maybe they
are not voting on policy maybe it's just
if they if they like the candidate
personally or not you know Barack Obama
is an entertaining guy Donald Trump's an
entertaining guy I could see a lot of
people having voted for both of them and
you know maybe they'll have to choose
the sexiest can at the next time around
again the other problem Paul with what
you're suggesting
and again you're thinking of the right
things it's just what I'm seeing is
maybe the possible holes in it is many
times voters vote against their own best
interests particularly Republican voters
so you might get a voter who says oh I
would vote for a Democrat if I believed
that they were going to lead lead me to
a better health care situation and then
they actually end up voting for the
Republican anyway because they either
don't understand the positions of the -
or fall victims to propaganda or
whatever so the questions you're asking
or proposing asking are great questions
but we have to make sure that it's
actionable in a way that will work and I
worry that it's not right yeah I guess
I've always just kind of wondered - you
know and I like I like what a lot of
what you said just you know if there are
some people say you know who are in that
situation where they want better health
care but then they say well you know but
I can't vote for the Democrat because
well they're okay with you know a woman
being able to have an abortion you know
etc so so I'm gonna not vote for that
you know I wonder it's like the social
issues or that can hold back everything
else yeah that's another good point
that's another good point great question
Paul really appreciate it I think you're
thinking about exactly the right issues
that Democrats need to be thinking about
going towards the 2018 and 2020 election
no doubt about it all right very much
appreciate the call